hey guys it's Justine and we are back
with some more tech it has been such a
crazy quarantine as far as tech is
concerned so many products have been
launched and announced and today I'm
checking out the new surface headphones
to you the new Microsoft Surface go-to
and of course one of these surface type
covers to go with it I've covered the
previous version of the Microsoft go and
what I loved so much about the original
version was it is just such a small
portable little tiny device and now more
than ever if you're someone who is
trying to do a bunch of conference calls
zoom calls Microsoft teams meetings
whatever it is that you're doing this is
a really great device for that and I
will show you why I would prefer using
this for the iPad I know it's shocking
shocking what do I have
oh I don't have a nice but I have a
screwdriver there's a few different
models of the surface go to but this is
the 8th gen Intel Core i3 processor with
128 gigs of storage and 8 gigs of go RAM
put my screwdriver away I think we're
done with that now this is the Intel
Core i3 version here it is I love that
they label everything for you like you
need to know where the camera is
check microphone check audio we've got
you covered the surface is such a great
small little device like you just I I
really really like this thing it's got
its nice little hinge here which is
super sturdy see what else we have in
the box I already know this is gonna be
the power adapter spoilers and since
this is the LTE version this gives you a
nice a SIM card ejector let's get this
thing turned on and open up our keyboard
this will work as they perfectly find
standalone device without a keyboard but
having this really does change the game
I really like this color a lot it's so
thin the type pad covers are about $150
extra and they do come in two colors
this is the ice blue it also comes in a
poppy bread it seems more like a grey
than a blue this also has a micro SD
card slot for expandable storage heavy
SBC with a headphone jack it also has
the
in camera on the front and on the back
so what a lot about this is I've been
doing so many zoom calls and conference
calls Microsoft teams meetings the
camera configuration is on the front
here the problem with the iPads that
I've run into is the camera is actually
over here it definitely is a much better
placement if you're doing those types of
things so I do really like the way that
this is set up now I will have a nice
little cute small device for friendship
a little sign in here touch a Wi-Fi
there and we'll have your PC ready for
all you plan to do and if you'd like me
to stay quiet
just select the little microphone I
you're done we could be friends later oh
my gosh no now you're talking to me so
if we're it's finished setting this up
let's open up ed phones so that we can
test these outs with the surface go the
new surface new headphones have improved
sound quality plus battery life they say
that you can get about 20 hours of usage
and it also has adjustable noise
cancellation look at that it'll work
with your iphones and it's bluetooth so
basically it will work almost with
anything that is Butch's I really like
the previous version of these and I like
the peace of a black version it's a
really light
first test they're actually quite
comfortable let's continue setting this
up and test out the headphones and the
surface go
[Music]
surfaces all set up the headphones are
currently synced and what's cool about
this is these have dials on them so I
can adjust the volume over here and I
can adjust the amount of noise
cancellation over here so this has three
different settings so when I turn it it
will go to maximum noise cancellation
and then when I turn it a little this
way it will allow some pass-through
sound as she's talking to me right now
and then when I turn it all the way
it'll allow me to do an ambient sound
amplification so I can hear everything
around me just a little bit better which
I need because my hearing is absolute
trash anyway these headphones are
awesome the one thing that I do like
that they did update is these turn so
that they can rest very nicely on your
shoulder it's like a it's like a nice
hug for they sound great plus having 20
hours of battery life is pretty awesome
so I would put these back on and I'm
gonna watch one of my youtube videos so
you can also see it's controlling the
volume when I turn it on my head you
guys can't hear this I also can't hear
myself talking Wow Wow
sounds really good it's not Wow I think
I honestly can't even hear myself and
I'm loud so one of the reasons I really
want to show you guys this is to give
you another option because I feel like a
lot of people right now are trying to
find devices to get work done if you do
need something that is super simple and
cost effective just this simple low end
model would be enough to do some calls
to take notes picky bored isn't added
extra but depending upon what you're
doing with us like you could just use
this just like this as a tablet it does
have a full keyboard so I've been using
an Excel spreadsheet a lot recently for
tracking and cataloguing items and
animal crossing and also tracking turnip
prices if this doesn't make any sense to
you that's okay if it does make sense
you know that animal crossing life is
real anyway all things considered I can
now use this as my animal crossing
tracking device for all of my Excel
spreadsheets and I look forward to using
this more for doing some calls I do want
to show you guys what I was talking
about as far as the camera placement so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
show you guys just recording directly
from the camera on
iPad and on the Microsoft Surface go to
and it's really crazy because the eye
line is so incredibly different that it
really makes me think that Apple is
going to have to figure out some sort of
a solution to this because most of the
time when I'm using my iPad especially
the stock now to the magic keyboard this
is the way that I'm using it I'm using
it horizontally so we do my little video
test first up I've got my Microsoft
teens meeting here on my surface go and
I'm not gonna look directly at the
camera I'm gonna look kind of below the
camera where the people would be hi it's
just ena checking in here for our
meeting I have arrived prompt as always
yeah that's that's cool yeah so I'm
gonna send you the document as soon as I
get off of this call right now I'm
currently doing really important things
like I'm trying to find a 600-plus
turnip island so I don't know if you can
just like hold off on asking me to do
anything for like the next four days so
right now I'm going to show you what it
looks like if I'm looking directly at
the camera so I'm looking at the camera
directly now and now I'm looking down
slightly to myself and looking over here
to the left to one of my friends over
there and I'm looking over here to one
of my friends over here it's a really
great dress it's really really great so
now it's time to do a group FaceTime
call with all of my friends so I'm gonna
hit record here so you can see what this
looks like I have pushed this so far
forward so that I'm actually in the shot
it's such a strange camera placement for
doing things like this so this is me
looking at up here kind of where the
Apple pencil is where the Microsoft
Surface Go camera actually would be so
if I'm doing a call with people I'm now
looking around the screen wondering if
anybody wants to talk to me I'm looking
off to the to the top right just the top
left kind of looking down and this is me
looking at the center of the screen does
anybody have anything that they want to
say to me any friends that are here no
okay but I will say that if I do flip
this thing around
this is perfect placement so if I'm
doing a call like this because I'm fully
gonna frame this looks great but I'm
then using my iPad like this in it how I
made it no tight I'm not now that my
conference calls are over we can have a
chat
I think the Microsoft Surface go to
checks a lot of boxes for a lot of
people on a lot of different levels this
can be used for word processing it can
be used for simple apps and games and I
can also be used for doing all of those
conference calls and if you are getting
the base model it is a really great
price obviously the iPad and this are
two very different devices I feel like
the iPad is definitely geared towards
doing more things like drawing video
production of course it is an iOS device
I know a lot of you guys out there are
Windows users and Android fans so
something like this might be perfect for
you well thank you guys for watching
this video if you guys have any
questions about this device or anything
in general feel free to leave those in
the comments below and I will see you in
my next video bye
[Music]